really give me some context here I mean
how unusual is what we're seeing play
out between the Celtics and the
Cavaliers it's not unusual sometimes
even though you exchange all the medical
information beforehand things come up
when they do a physical doctors may look
at it and have different opinions and
the doctors from the previous team and
so behind the scenes there's
negotiations to go on and to try to make
it work so it's not unusual it's just
with this deal at the magnitude of it
it's everybody's talking about it but
it's not unusual that this happens there
are some areas of the body where an
injury is okay a guy is an elbow injury
you could live with that everything
misses a couple of weeks how serious as
a general manager how serious is a hip
injury you're thinking about acquiring a
player well yeah hip is very tricky in
the sense of you know if it's a tear of
the labrum you know does it need surgery
you know how long it's gonna be and you
don't know how people's body's gonna
react when they start running and
putting pressure on that hip again and
so that's where are you really concerned
when you start within the hips and
shoulders and things of nature that
don't really have injuries because it
when a player injures the hip it's a
major injury or a shoulder knees you
know you have torn cartilage even ACLs
they repair quick and they tend to come
back shoulders and hips are very tricky
and so especially your hips and so I
think it's one that you've got to be
careful just because you don't know how
if a play when they have surgery you
know okay it's fixed when they don't
have surgery you hoping the body heals
itself if it doesn't then generally
surgery did usually cut follows that so
that's where the concern is not having
surgery not knowing how his body's gonna
react once he starts putting pressure
back on there is it any more or less
significant when it's a smaller player a
guy the size of Isaiah Thomas well I
think it's you know the heavier players
of not being a doctor here but I think
the more weight that the player puts on
it as a player is very athletic and he's
jumping and you know put a lot of
pressure on it with the torque of
jumping but III don't think I haven't
talked to any doctors that the size
matters it may so I would hate to
go out there but I just think when
you're dealing with the hip it's just
something that's very very tricky when
you know we I think Sam Dalembert when
he played for us he had a little hip
problem and you know we dealt with it
but it didn't require surgery talking to
Billy King former Nets the Sixers
general manager joining me here Dan
Patrick show all right so what do you
imagine the conversations are like now
in the next couple of days between the
Celtics and the Cavaliers well I think
now it's probably pretty pretty intense
I'm pretty testy because of the fact of
when you make a trade nowadays ambient
you have to know before you even get on
the trade call of the week you have to
disclose every all the medical
information and knowing what is hip and
everybody knowing is hip because it what
happened on the playoffs
I'm sure Boston gave them every piece of
medical information they had and writing
a lot of times we have the two doctors
talked beforehand you exchange MRIs
x-rays anything you have you have to
give gift to them and so from the Boston
standpoint they've got to be a little
probably frustrated because we know we
probably gave everything but from
Cleveland standpoint okay we had
anything now we examine them our doctors
have a little different opinion and so I
think it's the Cleveland Clinic that he
was supposed to go see again so it's
yeah you wonder how much information
that they have before even before
anybody with the aprile's
some things they can't disclose and not
less not until they're on the trade call
it doesn't sound Billy like the
Cavaliers want to void this deal
it sounds like they just want a
sweetener to make it work for them we've
heard the name Jason Tatum and Jalen
Brown floored that seems pretty
ludicrous to me I think a first-round
pick might be off the table as well what
would you imagine would be an acceptable
sweetener for the Celtics to throw in
here well I think the Cleveland's trying
to get another asset from it whether
it's a first-round pick I think a second
something that you know they would take
but I think they're trying to get a
first if they can and get another first
forward because that they're looking at
not having Isiah Thomas possibly the
beginning of season and if you need
surgery maybe most of the season so I
think they're trying to get another
asset so that they can say okay at least
we've got two picks two first-round
picks for that for that asset for you
know for him not being able to play you
know well that Derrick Rose
and work from there but from Boston
standpoint I think they're in a tough
situation because you've already trade
as a Thomas he's a little frustrated but
he knows but I think if they bring him
back and say okay it didn't go through
we tried to trade you it happened you
got to come back and you know and get
healthy if he's not able to play you
know they play Terry Rozier and there's
other guys they still have all their
assets Cleveland then in return has the
Kyrie Irving who wants out and so now
they've got to go and try to find a deal
that's better than the one that's on
today what Boston now if we could find
that which team is it more problematic
for if this trade gets void to Cleveland
or Boston well I think it'd be Cleveland
from my standpoint because I think
you'll have a frustrated Kyrie Irving
now LeBron probably frustrated because
the fact is he was probably pretty
excited about this deal so I think from
Cleveland standpoint and they got to go
every group and try to make it another
trade and now everybody knows even more
that you've got to trade them before you
know with a month to go before training
camps or Boston you can have some hurt
feelings you know Isaiah Thomas come
back hurt but I think boss and then
we'll have all their of their assets
that have Crowder back and you know and
then they've got players that can fill
in they can't score like Isaiah Thomas
but they have players that can fill in
and they can continue to build if they
don't rob if this trade falls apart if
I'm Cleveland I bring Kyrie Irving to
camp I say screw it I say get two years
left on your contract
maybe we'll revisit this December 15th
when guys that can be traded they're
signed in the offseason can be traded
but I mean what when I talk to Cleveland
players Billy the one thing they tell me
is that our entire team exists in a
consistent state of dysfunction we are
we are where we're constantly there's
constant drama from the Kevin Love stuff
to David Blatt I mean there's never
there's very few smooth days in the
Cavaliers organization I think there are
people inside that organization that
believe they can ride this out and bring
Kyrie to camp and still be the best team
in Eastern Conference and maybe deal him
a little bit later down the line yeah
but I think this is different I think
when Kevin was talked about being
possibly traded Kevin Love
you know it was a possibility this is
one where he was trade he asked for
trade he got traded comes back
you go back to the the video of him at
the wedding with Steph Curry and I think
the media scrutiny on this will make it
even make it more difficult to succeed
because I think everybody will be
looking for anything is if Kyrie throws
a pass LeBron it wasn't on target people
say oh look that you know he was trying
to mess up the past so I think it'll be
I think this one would be very very
difficult I think the Walker would be
very toxic even though they say they
lived in dysfunction this would be to
toxically I think for them to succeed
it's set a bad precedent though a guy
with two years left this contract who
just coming off a a third straight final
season and they're like wouldn't you
want to tell him to shut up and play
well I think that's been going on I know
the league put rules and replayed Amanda
trade but they do it behind the scenes
with their agent thing at that and I
think that's what that's been happening
in the league where guys have two years
guys have three years and they said they
went out and teams you know you trade
them because it's you know better for
the cohesion and locker room but yeah
this is it's it's not right but but it
then again if you look at it from the
Isiah Thomas situation
his sister passed away he goes and plays
and flies back four plays in a play
knows plays hurt and gets traded and so
it's a two-way street no teams do things
that players don't like by making trades
that they say I'm loyal to you now you
trade me or players things are loyal to
them they want to be traded so I think
it's been happening for both sides where
teams trade guys or you know who want to
be want to stay where they are and
players leaves and teams want them to
stay so it's been happening in MBA and I
think it's going to continue happen
which is not good for the league because
I think the fans want some kind of
loyalty to them not to you know if
you're not gonna be loyal to your
franchise or not gonna be a little or
the team's I can blow it to the player
please somebody be loyal to the fans I
think that's what the fans looking for
because they're paying their heart our
money they want loyalty back to them you
think the deal gets done I think it does
I think they'll end up getting it done I
think Boston may Sweden and they won't
sweeten it to you know whatever is
reported I think Jason Tatum or or brown
put in won't happen but I think I think
it does get done because in the day
click Cleveland you're not you meant you
know may not get a healthy Isiah Thomas
but you're getting a hell of a pic and
you're getting J Crowder I think it's a
big part of the deal you get in the
young center so I think they're getting
some assets that can help them going
forward because I think they're a team
there was an older team now getting some
young pics going forward helps them
rebuild so the Ultima build safe LeBron
leaves or and even if Isaiah is not able
to come back till January you're gonna
get an idea Thomas it's gonna be very
motivated to go out there and prove to
everybody I'm not saying that I know
that's when he'll be back but I think he
can get back on the court when he does
he'll be a motivated player and you
still got the best player in the world
in the Bron James so you can try to
squeeze Boston but I think Boston is you
know if if they take a step back and
don't get to the Conference Finals
they're still young enough they can
continue so I don't think they'll give
up any more than they have and I say
that Tatum or Brown they may so in the
Memphis pick but that may be a good pick
down the road as they started to rebuild
in there so you know maybe they don't
want to protect a pick or something like
that to try this get it to go and you
know go away because they are getting a
heck of players on the contract in Kyrie
Irving you gotta be sad to see that last
Nets pick leave Boston well you know
it's it's something that happened you
know it's gonna stick with me and you
know I understand that but at the time
as I've told you before in your podcast
you know at that time ownership and meds
but we had a plan and the plan changed
and you know and that's the prerogative
ownership so but I will be glad when
it's over with just just blame Bobby
marks I do you know the one thing as I
said when when I was there is I told
ownership when I took the job I said hey
we're we all make this is together as a
group and you know we're gonna be as a
group but I looked at it we did that as
a group and it didn't work and they made
a decision to go in a different
direction and I'm still friends with
Mikhail and Dmitri and I wish them luck
but
you know that's the that's the business
that I chose to be it hey always great
to busy visit with you Billy
appreciate the time you're welcome take
care guys that's Billy King the former
net Sixers GM joining me here on the Dan
Patrick show the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience